all right doctor so um with the big
announcement here with uh
cbs uh doing the rollout for the covet
19 vaccines do we know here in nevada
what locations what areas is this gonna
be happening at
yes so we currently have three stores
in our cloud clark county area that
we'll be rolling out
this weekend so you will be able to book
appointments this saturday march 13th
and then we will be starting to give
vaccines sunday march 14th
okay so the earliest you can register is
saturday
uh but then the actual vaccine itself
will happen on sunday
yes correct okay do we know what those
three stores where those are
so the exact locations unfortunately we
don't want to share at this time the
reason being
our pharmacy teams will be inundated and
overwhelmed with phone calls and people
coming in
so at this time we cannot give those
locations yet
okay and obviously the big question that
folks um keep asking is you know
at these locations what vaccines what
brand
are we gonna be able to get so it will
be either pfizer or mederna
um at these stores that we will be
giving or providing
okay not the the johnson johnson
uh not currently johnson johnson at this
time no
okay and then obviously that's my next
question with um the
with this with the jensen vaccine uh
currently stopped here by state
officials
um do you think that this at all is
going to have some sort of impact
uh with the rollout for cbs it will not
have any impact with our rollout we will
still
keep continue either to do pfizer or
moderna
and then of course we will continue to
add stores as weeks go on
so just be on the lookout for that
awesome and then last question hardest
one probably
um where can people make an appointment
this is actually the easiest one for me
so i've we've been training our folks so
everybody knows in our stores but
they can go to cvs.com there will be a
tab
on there as well as our cvs app
you can make an appointment off of there
if you do not
have any kind of internet
or capability through your smartphone we
do have a phone number 1 800 shop cvs
they will be able to make an appointment
through there as well